Denis is vacationing in China and wants  to spend $30 on a new sweater the  sweater he likes cost 197 Chinese won  one u.s. dollar can be converted into  six Chinese won  Denis will have blank Chinese won if he  converts his $30 well just think about  this he's going to take $30 in the  conversion rate is six one per dollar so  he's going to have $30 times six ones  per dollar she's gonna have 30 times six  wons and thirty times six well that's  the same thing as three times six times  ten or 180 so he's going to have a  hundred and eighty Chinese won  now does he have enough money to buy the  sweater well the sweater cost 197 one so  no he does not have enough money to buy  the sweater